THIS IS "SPECIAL REPORT" ."
GOOD EVENING AND WELCOME TO
WASHINGTON, I'M BRET BAIER.
THE U.S. SUPREME COURT HAS LET
STAND THE PRESIDENT'S TRAVEL BAN
THE WHITE HOUSE HAD FRAMED THE
RULE AS CRUCIAL FOR NATIONAL
SECURITY.
OPPONENTS CALLED IT RELIGIOUS
DISCRIMINATION.
IS AT THE SUPREME COURT WITH
WHAT HAPPENED AND WHY, ALONG
WITH THE IMPLICATIONS GOING
FORWARD.
GOOD EVENING.
>> HELLO.
THE MAJORITY MADE CLEAR TODAY
THAT THE PRESIDENT WAS WELL
WITHIN HIS POWERS UNDER THE LAW
COUNTRY.
IT'S A VICTORY FOR THEM TODAY
BUT THIS CASE IS ACTUALLY NOT
OVER.
>> NO BAND, NO WALL!
>> AFTER MORE THAN A YEAR OF
LEGAL WRANGLING, BOSSES AND THE
LOWER COURT AND THREE DIFFERENT
VERSIONS OF THE PRESIDENT'S
SO-CALLED TRAVEL BAN HAS BEEN
PLAIN LANGUAGE, FEDERAL LAW
GRANTS THE PRESIDENT BROAD
DISCRETION TO DEFEND THE ENTRY
OF ALIENS INTO THE
UNITED STATES.
THE PRESIDENT LAWFULLY EXERCISE
THAT DISCRETION BASED ON HIS
FINDINGS FOLLOWING A WORLDWIDE
DETRIMENTAL TO THE NATIONAL
INTEREST.
>> WHAT WE ARE DOING IS LOOKING
AT COUNTRIES IN A RATIONAL WAY.
THE VETTING PROCESS WORKS AND
TERRORISM IS NOT A PROBLEM.
>> WITH THE MAJORITY DIDN'T DO
PRESIDENT TRUMP TO DECIDE
WHETHER THE BAN WAS VOTED BY
RELIGIOUS ANIMUS.
THE PROCLAMATION IS EXPRESSLY --
THE TEXT SAYS NOTHING ABOUT
RELIGION.
BUT IN ONE OF TWO PASSIONATE
DISSENT, JUSTICE SOTO
MAYOR BLAST OF THE MAJORITY FOR
NOT LOOKING TO MR. TRUMP'S
STATEMENTS.
ANTI-MUSLIM ANIMUS.
THE MAJORITY HOLDS OTHERWISE BY
IGNORING THE FACT, MISCONSTRUING
OUR LEGAL PRECEDENTS AND TURNING
A BLIND EYE TO THE PAIN AND
SUFFERING THE PROCLAMATION
INFLICTS UPON COUNTLESS FAMILIES
AND INDIVIDUALS.
>> THIS IS REALLY A SAD DAY FOR
AMERICA.
BIGOTRY AND A ISLAMOPHOBIA.
>> THE MAJORITY AND DISSENT ALSO
SPARRED OVER COMPARISONS TO A
1944 RULING UPHOLDING A
PRESIDENTIAL DIRECTIVE ORDERING
JAPANESE-AMERICANS INTO
INTERNMENT CAMPS IN
WORLD WAR II.
THAT DECISION FOR MORE THAN
SEVEN DECADES AGO.
WRITING "INQUIRE MUCH OF THE
COURT GAVE A PASS TO AN ODIOUS,
GREATLY INJURIOUS RACIAL
PACIFICATION AUTHORIZED BY AN
REJECTED THE COMPARISON."
KOREMATSU HAS NOTHING TO DO WITH
NEUTRAL POLICY DENYING CERTAIN
FOREIGN NATIONALS THE PRIVILEGE
OF ADMISSION.
>> THE CASE DOESN'T END HERE
OR NOT AN INJUNCTION AGAINST THE
TRAVEL BAN 3.0 COULD STAND
BURIED TODAY WITH THIS GUIDANCE
FROM THE JUSTICE IT GOES BACK TO
THE LOWER COURT FOR A DECISION
ACTUALLY ON THE MERIT.
>> Bret: THERE WAS ALSO
ANOTHER RULING INVOLVING A
CRISIS CENTERS IN CALIFORNIA.
>> THEY MANAGED TO SCOOP UP ALL
THE PRO-LIFE PREGNANCY CENTERS,
ALMOST ALL OF THEM IN THE STATES
ESSENTIALLY TELLING THEM THEY
HAD TO PROVIDE ALL KINDS OF
INFORMATION TO POTENTIAL CLIENTS
INCLUDING ABOUT WHERE THEY COULD
HAVE TWO ENCOURAGE WOMEN TO
CARRY THEIR PREGNANCIES TO TERM.
IT WAS A 5-4 DECISION WRITTEN BY
GOOD CHANCE THESE CLINICS WERE
GOING TO PREVAIL TO THE MERIT SO
HE SET THE CASE BACK TO
CALIFORNIA TO DEAL WITH IT.
>> Bret: STILL WAITING ON ONE
MORE?
>> TOMORROW WE ARE WAITING ON A
BIG CASE ON WHETHER OR NOT
PUBLIC SECTOR EMPLOYEES CAN BE
FORCED TO PAY DUES TO EUNICE THE